uh and with that in mind let's bring in
san antonio spurs head coach greg
popovich who joined us now from the
nba bubble in orlando we appreciate you
being here coach no one could have
predicted
that we would be in this seminal moment
so you've candidly said this is an
opportunity for the league
players and coaches to do something
transformative tell us why you believe
that's the case
i think it's a it's our responsibility
it's a necessity
considering what's going on in our
country and
hopefully the realization by many people
mostly white who begin to understand
what it's been like for the black
population so
adam silver and the nba have done a
great job in putting this back together
uh i don't know if there's a safer place
on earth
than we are right now but
since we are here since we're gonna play
some games we have a responsibility to
keep the conversation going
and that's going to be a main
kind of a mantra for all of us players
coaches
gm's everybody that's here is going to
stick to that
because it's an opportunity
to make sure this momentum does not stop
pop you've been vocal for so very long
all of us know that
your shirt says vote your life depends
on it you've never shied away from
talking about white privilege what you
think this country needs to do
differently
how's that conversation going with your
players why are you in the bubble
i think that well i don't think i know
it's
it's going great with with all the teams
uh both in and out of the bubble
uh by out i mean the people who are not
here
but uh you know i got to give credit
uh to lloyd pierce the head coach in
atlanta
he's put together a committee
of coaches to make sure
that we're all understanding the fact
that
we have to do anything possible
to educate in those 30
nba cities and he's been working night
and day
to put a program together along with
other organizations uh you know brian
stevens equal justice program
uh president obama's foundation
that sort of thing so we along with the
players
uh have committed to making sure that
once the games begin and even before
that on a daily basis
we make sure that this is upfront and in
everybody's
mind you know coach a lot of
conversation about the coronavirus
obviously and
how it affects older coaches and your
name came up
you talking about me charles
yeah hey that was you
coach d'antoni and alvin gentry were the
first three names
how concerned are you about that to be
honest
i am i don't i don't want to die uh
i wear my mask all the time i took it
off to talk to you guys
uh right here but uh
if if you have half a brain you have to
take this seriously and understand that
people of all ages
are coming up with this disease the
older you are the more susceptible you
might be
and even if you get through it it seems
that there are long lasting
complications whether it's lungs heart
brain or whatever else
so it behooves each of us who might be a
little bit older
to take it very seriously i wear my mask
in practice
and i only take it off when i got
something to say because i am concerned
you're exactly right
coach pop um you know i wanted switching
gears
uh i wanted to ask you so growing up in
saginaw michigan
i was hardly ever around any white
people i went to school it was
predominantly black
the recreation center i went to the
neighborhood i grew up in
as blacks we always unders we always
think
that white people should understand how
we feel should understand where we're
going to but the fact of the matter is
that's not the case because i can't say
i understand the life of somebody white
that's growing up and so how do
what what would you say to the world
about bridging that gap
and understanding each other better
because i think that is a huge part of
the divide it's just the
knowledge and education right
it's a great question and
my answer in the beginning might seem a
bit trite
but i think when you get down to the
root of everything it's all about
learning and educating
you know we've had a lot of meetings uh
both inside the organization just like
other teams have and the coaches the
players have had their meeting we've all
zoomed together
but really learning and understanding
other people's situations
is where it begins there's got to be
that discussion because
we are all in a sense clueless
to things that don't really affect us
i'll give you
i don't want to get too political but
well sure i do but
this is a great example of cluelessness
and this happened to be laura ingraham
you know the
lady who told lebron to just shut up and
dribble
and she said that that
basically a quote pretty close to a
quote paraphrase for sure
all of a sudden uh it became political
and nobody was paying any attention to
it all of a sudden all the statues had
to come down
but nobody was paying any attention to
it now just think
about that statement i don't know if she
meant harm or not i don't know if she's
trying to inflame or not
but it's a clueless comment by a white
person
because the white people probably didn't
pay any attention to it because it
didn't affect them
when they walked by a confederate statue
every day
and that's the education i'm talking
about to understand
what other people go through and that's
what you're talking about draymond you
know you have to have that
discussion with people before they can
understand
and you have to educate and with all of
our 30 organizations
that's where it begins before you go out
and pontificate and talk to people about
what i just said
you've got to make sure your own house
is in order that the people in your
organization
feel comfortable in their environment so
that's what has to happen for the long
run you know in the meantime we want to
talk about
police brutality and about the
difference in pay the
the wealth gap reparations all these
things
but if we don't educate if the textbooks
don't change
if we don't all learn things in school
and even
the young black players on my team they
didn't they didn't they didn't know
about tulsa
they they don't know that between uh
the end of the civil war in about 1950
there were 6
500 lynchings they don't know that
nobody i didn't know that nobody told us
that stuff
so people have to know why
we are why where we're at uh coach pop
thank you so much for joining us you
always give an education and you speak
from your hearts